what's my safe word that'd be hilarious  what if one of us guessed it  is it a single word or a single word I  can't wait to see this all right ready  one two three pineapple pineapple  book my safe word  is autopsy  it works like a charm yeah it's a very  effective I don't know the safest word I  thought this is so hard to say yeah like  that's not like in my like if you're  having sex I feel like you'd be like oh  pineapple three syllable words bigger  question how many times have you yes  this safe once one yeah just one time  just once so you've discussed this with  every guy that you've been with how long  has it been your safe word or do you  have a different safe word for each guy  oh good question wait I can dig let's  take it